one of the things i talk about in 12
rules for life and this has been in my
lectures this has become a meme
strangely enough something that's widely
distributed on the web partly because
there's a comical element to it it's to
clean up your room
and everyone laughs about that because
i'm taking that seriously it's like oh
clean up your room everyone's mother has
told them that a thousand times right
but i try to explain why it's like well
you have a bit of chaotic potential
right in front of you it's in some sense
infinite in its potential and the the
domain in which you can manipulate that
might be rather restricted
because of the restrictions that that
are part and parcel of your existence
but maybe you have your room it isn't a
room it's a place of potential and as
soon as you know that then it's it's not
your room anymore it isn't a room the
room that you see
is your preconception of the space that
you inhabit what's there is
is a fragment of infinity that's what's
there
and what you see
is the low resolution consequence of
your assumption and lazy habit and
blindness that's your initial room and
you think well no that's not the room
see part of what artists do for example
when van gogh paints a room and you look
at it glowing he's trying to show you
what's beyond your perception
of the room and i mean this technically
like the way that your visual system is
set up is that whenever memory and
presumption can
replace direct perception it will
because it's simpler so you literally
see what you expect to see and if what
you see is dull and drab and boring and
pointless and uninspiring then that's
you
it's not what's there and what the
artist does when he or she re-represents
that mundane reality is to remind you of
what's behind it the potential that's
there and so what i'm suggesting to
people is that they take the potential
that's right in front of them it's like
okay and here's the rule you're aiming
up there's something that you could
change
that you would change that might be a
very small thing could well that's
within the grasp of your power wood is
within the grasp of your will to combine
those two things might be very small
shift you might only be willing to make
a very tiny step forward it's like fine
good enough make a tiny step forward and
that makes you a slight bit stronger
than you were before and then the next
step can be slightly larger and it's
it's the path of humility now people who
are hoarding are often older or
neurologically damaged or they have
obsessive-compulsive disorder but then
you walk into their house and there's
like ten thousand things in their house
there's maybe a hundred boxes and you
open up a box and in the box there's
some pens and some old passports and
some checks and their collection of
silver dollars and some hypodermic
needles and some dust and you know a
dead mouse and there's boxes and boxes
and boxes like that in the house it's
absolute chaos in there absolute chaos
not order chaos and then you think is
that their house or is that their being
is that their mind and the answer is
there's no difference so you know i
could say well if you want to organize
your psyche you could start by
organizing your room if that would be
easier because maybe you're a more
concrete person and you need something
concrete to do so you go clean up under
your bed and you make your bed and you
organize the papers on your desk and you
think well just exactly what are you
organizing are you organizing the
objective world are you organizing your
field of being like your field of total
experience there's no difference between
you and what you experience now you
think well i can't control everything i
experience but that's no objection
because you can't control yourself
anyway so the mere fact that you can't
extend control over everything you
experience is no argument against the
idea that you should still treat that as
an extension of yourself what could you
do to improve yourself
well let's step one step backwards the
first question might be why should you
even bother improving yourself the
answer to that is something like so you
don't suffer any more stupidly than you
have to and maybe so others don't have
to either it's something like that you
know like there's a real injunction at
the bottom of it it's not some casual
self-help doctrine it's that if you
don't organize yourself properly you'll
pay for it and in a big way and so will
the people around you and you could say
well i don't care about that but that's
actually not true you actually do care
about that because if you're in pain you
will care about it and so you do care
about it even if it's just that negative
way you know it's very rare that you can
find someone who's in excruciating pain
who would ever say well it would be no
better if i was out of this
sort of pain is one of those things that
brings the idea that it would be better
if it didn't exist along with it it's
incontrovertible so you get your act
together so that there isn't any more
stupid pain around you than necessary
well so then the question might be well
how would you go about getting your act
together and the answer to that and this
is a phenomenological idea too it's
something like look around for something
that bothers you and see if you can fix
it you can do this in a room it's quite
fun to do it just when you're sitting in
a room like a room maybe your bedroom
you can sit there and just sort of
meditate on and think okay if i wanted
to spend 10 minutes making this room
better what would i have to do and you
have to ask yourself that right it's not
a command it's like a genuine question
and things will pop out in the room that
you know you like there's a stack of
papers over there that's kind of bugging
you and you know that maybe a little
order there would be a good thing and
there's some rubbish behind your
computer monitor that you haven't
attended to for like six months and the
room would be slightly better if it was
a little less dusty and the cables
weren't all tangled up the same way and
if you allow yourself just to consider
the expanse in which you exist at that
moment there'll be all sorts of things
that'll pop out in it that you could
just fix and you know i might say well
if you were coming to see me for
psychotherapy the small easiest thing
for us to do first would just be to get
you to organize your room you think well
is that psychotherapy and the answer is
well it depends on how you conceive the
limits of your being and i would say
start where you can start if if
something announces itself to you which
is a strange way of thinking about it as
in need of repair that you could repair
then hey
fix it you fix a hundred things like
that your life will be a lot different
now i often tell people to fix the
things you repeat every day because
people tend to think of those as trivial
right you get up you brush your teeth
you have your breakfast you know you
have your routines that you go through
every day well those probably constitute
50 percent of your life
and people think well they're mundane i
don't need to pay attention to them it's
like no no that's exactly wrong the
things you do every day those are the
most important things you do hands down
all you have to do is do the arithmetic
you figure it out right away so 100
adjustments to your broader domain of
being and there's a lot less rubbish
around it a lot fewer traps for you to
step into and so once you've got your
mind and your emotions together and once
you're acting that out then you can
extend what you're willing to consider
yourself and start fixing up the things
that are part of your broader extent
it's very interesting thing to do i like
that i like the idea of the room because
you can do that at the drop of a hat you
know go back to where you live and sit
down and think okay i'm going to make
this place better for half an hour what
should i do you have to ask and things
will just pop up like mad and it's
partly because your mind is a very
strange thing as soon as you give it a
name a genuine name it'll reconfigure
the world in keeping with that aim that
that's actually how you see to begin
with and so if you set it a task
especially you have to be genuine about
it which is why you have to bring your
thoughts and emotions together and then
you have to get them in your body so
you're acting consistently you have to
be genuine about the aim but once you
aim the world will reconfigure itself
around that aim which is very strange
and it's technically true you know the
best example of that you have all seen
this video where you watch the
basketballs being tossed back and forth
between members of the white team versus
the black team and while you're doing
that a gorilla walks up into the middle
of the video and you don't see it it's
like you know if you thought about that
experiment for about five years that
would be about the right amount of time
to spend thinking about it because what
it shows you is that you see what you
aim at and that man if you can get one
thing through your head
as a consequence of even being in
university that would be a good one you
see what you aim at right what you aim
at determines the way the world
manifests itself to you and so if the
world is manifesting itself in a very
negative way
one thing to ask is are you aiming at
the right thing you got to be oriented
towards something
because otherwise you're disoriented you
just spin around in circles and then you
suffer and sort of people around you
it's not a good solution orient yourself
towards something you have to figure out
what it is what will work for you what
goal
would would justify the suffering of
your life start trying to piece that
together you're going to get better at
it but it's a personal process and you
should use your education to inform that
so you need a personal place to stand
because otherwise you're going to be
handed a place to stand on a plate and
it may be one that that makes you a
puppet of someone else's goals
so i would say
what are what are the processes well i
think
what i've recommended to people is clean
up your room that's a good start
organize your local landscape schedule
your time start taking control of
yourself you start small it's not small
you think it's small it's not small i
had a girl come up to me last night at
the end of my talk she said i started
cleaning up my room last year and it
completely changed my life she said your
room is an externalization of your mind
and that's right that's exactly true to
the degree that you're in your room
the room is you now that isn't how
people think but that's okay it doesn't
matter if they think that way that's how
it is so
straighten up what you can straighten up
and quit saying things that make you
feel weak and then then you'll know what
to do next
[Music]